Hey,
I grabbed the wrong book, man.
It's the gray one.
I'm losing it.
Getting old.
You that one?
This morning I wor my glasses.
[Arabic recitation]
cuz I've looked for my glasses for
my glasses. They were on my face the
whole time. It's aside from the times
I'm looking for a pen. It's in my hand.
I'm looking for my phone. I'm I'm speed
talking on it.
Thank you.
Continuing
in the fifth chapter, we're at the very
end of the fifth chapter, the chapter of
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
observation.
The eighth narration in this chapter is
on the authority of Ab
who narrates.
[Silence]
This narration is one of the more
well-known narrations.
it is a strong difference of opinion
amongst the scholars of hadith as to the
authenticity of this narration. The
scholars differ on whether these are the
words of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam or these are the words of some
of the companions of
however
this is an issue of it. Some scholars
view the authenticity level to be just
enough to get it through the to get it
to the threshold of authenticity
whilst others view it falling slightly
short. However, one of the beautiful
things about
and why this book is one of the more
renowned books of hadith, probably one
of the most ubiquitous and commonplace
books of narration after Bkari Muslim in
the whole world.
There is no book printed in the world
more in the Islamic library after the
mus than
it is number two even
more than Bkari even more than the
summaries of Bkari.
Now there's a couple of reasons for that
but for our intents and purposes
one of the key features of
is that whilst there may be a few
narrations in there that are differed
upon their authenticity amongst the
scholars of hadith
some which
are weak narrations.
However, any
weak narration
has two features. Number one, its
weakness is very slight.
It is not a very weak hadith. It's
slightly weak. When we have we go back
to what we discussed yesterday with
respect to
a narration not meeting the criteria of
authentic falling just short of
authentic.
We mention a narrator. When when when we
say a narration is authentic
that means that we are mostly certain
there is no reasonable doubt
that this narration is not the words of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
That's what that means. Right?
Now when we look at a weak narration,
a weak narration is merely saying there
is a reasonable doubt
that it is not the words of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. So we have a chain
of narration. In that chain of narration
there's a man who is trustworthy. All of
the people in the chain of narration are
trustworthy.
However, one of them is less known,
right? This is called
or for instance, one of them is
trustworthy, but he's been known to make
a few mistakes
in his career, in his whole career.
Okay,
this here is strong or weak.
, this is extreme or slight
weakness. This is slight weakness.
This is slight weakness.
Extreme weakness is someone who's known
to fumble the majority of what he
narrates. more than 60 70% of what
he narrates, he makes a mistake. That's
extreme weakness. Or someone who is
known to not only make mistakes, but
people will tell him and then he'll
follow whoever tells him whatever.
That's extreme weakness. Or for
instance, someone who lies, someone
who's known to have lied, someone who's
known to have not been able to discern
between lies and truths with respect to
the prophet's sunnah. This here is
extreme weakness.
Slight weakness means that this person
cannot take us to the level of certainty
to where there's no reasonable doubt.
There is a reasonable doubt. Right? That
slight weakness
is different than having an extreme and
serious weakness. In real,
if we were to gather all the reasonably
weak narrations,
even in the most extreme
of
med, the most strict med of hadith
authenticity, there would be no more
than a hundred weak narrations. That's
out of almost 2,000.
So that's
less than less than 10% less than 5%.
But
in addition to that
we see that they're more reasonably
around 70 weak narrations about 74 right
in a moderate med.
However, all of those
are slight in weakness
and their meaning is correct.
The meaning of the actual words of the
narration are correct. Meaning what?
Meaning in other
parts of the Quran, parts of the Sunnah,
these meanings are bolstered by the rest
of the Sunnah. They are bolstered by the
Quran. It's a meaning that coincides and
fits with the patterns of the Quran and
Sunnah. So yes, chain of narration wise,
there's weakness. That weakness is not
only slight but it is not a narration.
There's no narrations in
that go against the the principles of
the Quran and Sunnah. The meaning is
correct. Right? So this is being one of
those. However, this narration
in the correct opinion is of the
authentic narrations.
It is
It is acceptable due to other narrations
that bolster its meaning. Abu narrates
that the messenger of Allah sallall.aii
wasallam says
it is of
a man's it is of the
perfection of an of a man's Islam that
he leave off what does not concern him.
It is of the perfection of a man's
Islam.
Remember we spoke about
what is
that you worship Allah as if you can see
him. For if you cannot see him, he is
observing you. And so it is of the
perfection of the
of the levels of
of a of a man's Islam that he leave off
what does not concern him.
One of the things that one of our
one of one of my more senior
teachers in hadith, one of the things
that he used to tell us often is
a yard stick, a measuring stick. If you
want to see
and gauge a man's mind to see if he's a
person of intellect or if he's a person
of foolishness,
look at how he spends his time. And if
you want to gauge a man's dean, the
veracity of his religiosity,
then look at what he does with his
tongue.
These are two indicators. If you see a
man that is wasting his time killing
time, anybody tells him come here, he's
just chatting until they tell him go,
right? he's not busy trying to
excel in this life or the next. This
person is not
of the most intellectual.
And if you'd to look at the
veracity of a person's dean, I want to
know if this is a this person is of
perfect Islam or is of best Islam.
Someone who truly fears Allah, listen to
how they speak. If they are in constant
remembrance of Allah, if they mind what
concerns them, if they do not delve into
issues that are not their concern, if
they concern themselves with that which
is certain, then this is a person who
has worked very hard to discipline
himself upon his dean. And this is
someone who is is someone who is
aware of Allah's observation at all
times. If you see, he is a person that
is backbiting people, speaking ill about
others, is constantly obsessed with
other people and what they're doing and
putting down other people and try in
order to try to bolster themselves up.
This person's dean is very weak. This
person's deal is very weak. And so our
prophet Sam
here tells us
it is of the perfection
and the discipline of a man in his dean
and his Islam that he leave off what
does not concern him. concern him of
this dunya, his profession, earning
providing a a secure living, secure
livelihood or of the next life, right?
Even when it comes to hobbies, person
has a hobby.
Let's say a person's hobby is
just to
you know something that is
has zero has zero benefit. No matter how
you slice it, it is it c it cannot
benefit in any way in this life or the
hereafter. It's mentioned
was brought a man and this man was so
skilled he had practiced for so many
thousands of hours
that he was able to set up a needle
and throw another needle through the eye
of that needle.
Amazing, right? Harun and Rashid ordered
that he be flogged 10 times, that he be
whipped 10 times for that, and that he
be given
100 din for that. They said, "You
gave him money and you had him whipped?"
He said, "Yes, I had him whipped for
wasting time on such a silly thing,
but I gave him money for the
perfection." At least the guy has has
pride in what he does, right?
So he gave him he gave him 100 dinar
pieces of gold for his his discipline
and for his dedication.
But he had him flogged for being such a
fool. before
[Arabic recitation]
know people will come and they want to
entertain the king. he was the Khalifa.
They want to entertain the Khalifa or
they want to show him something novel or
they're trying to get a job. Look, I'm
very skilled at this or that. This was
this guy's skill, right? So he's
watching in horror and awe
simultaneously
as this man showcases the thousands of
hours he spent to be able to do
something that is both remarkable and
of ultimate stupidity at the same time.
And soan
has its reward. However, that has to be
spent towards something. Even if it is
spent, even if a level of is achieved,
but it's achieved in something silly.
This means this person's mind is they're
not, you know, the elevator is not going
all the way to the top.
[Silence]
Why are there so many people here?